et
les répétitions en petits groupes sont
terminés place à la dernière ligne
droite
ce week-end ses écoliers saint
quentinois seront sur la scène du
théâtre national
cette confédération est importante parce
que au début ils ont du mal à comprendre
par exemple pourquoi il ya un champ ils
chantent ils s'arrêtent ils chantent ils
s'arrêtent alors que là une fois que
tout le monde est ensemble ils
comprennent l'enjeu ils comprennent la
construction de ce projet est en fait il
se rend vraiment compte qu'ils ont
construit quelque chose ensemble et ça
va leur donner de grandes émotions
ensemble sur scène pour chanter l'arche
de noé de benjamin britten sept mois de
travail soutenu par l'éducation
nationale et les communes qui voit
notamment une ouverture culturelle la
deuxième vertu évidemment c'est
c'est une sorte de formation citoyenne
comme on dit c'est à dire tout ce qui
nous permet de faire en sorte que les
enfants soient entre eux deux enfants
deux lieux différents puisque les
enfants de trappes qui à les entendre la
verrière il y en a de montigné de
plusieurs communes dans les environs de
saint quentin en yvelines
ça développe tout un tas de choses dont
on n'a pas connaissance aujourd'hui
parce que comme c'est sûr de l'huma
chacun réagit en fonction de ses
sensibilités
il en reste toujours quelque chose qui
ressort à un moment donné il ne reste
plus que quelques répétitions pour ses
244 élèves saint quentinois
ils sont accompagnés par de nombreux
artistes dont les solistes de
lavilledieu avant de se lancer sur la
grande scène